was so full podcast was so full podcast
welcome to the were so full podcast with
Felipe Esparza and my co-host of the
year Rogelio Torres yeah man
and over here with facts Lisa Esparza
sometimes are correct facts sometimes
what's up fool what up yeah Aaron
looking at prince charming over here
chillin don't press the Charmin
alright upcoming shows January no
upcoming shows tonight it's gonna air we
believe that tomorrow what your face
anyway alright tonight
February 1st through a third that means
dumb actually the second the second or a
Naples Florida off the hook comedy club
February Levin Oakland California at the
Paramount Theater part of a big show
with DeRay Davis preacher Lawson Bruce
Bruce fortune spinster February 14
Corpus Christi Texas at American Bank
Center with Raymond Horta and Rodrigo
February 27 Lemoore California at tachi
casino only 65 degrees left February
23rd Las Vegas Nevada at Treasure Island
Casino February 24th Rochester
Washington at the luggage casino I
didn't know there were a Rochester
Washington lucky ego lucky ego
what did I say lucky casino tickets are
now on sale for my to love that no to
Los Angeles shows now March 23rd at the
Nova theater downtown LA because they're
almost sold out we're adding two more
shows on Saturday March 24 7 and 10
tickets go on sale today February 2nd at
ax s.com also opening up the show will
be mosquito stick to the facts
east of the river they're a big group
huh
yeah well it's several different rappers
that work independently but they are
performing together yeah lots more dates
check out Felipe world.com slash tour
people
I forgot my things comedy bag yesterday
that's him
we'll get it today sometimes we'll get
him now no luck without the boss King I
have bad news we're gonna give one of
you a backpack in one of you okay
suitcase I don't [ __ ] that we want
nothing that I'll just keep my way back
[Laughter]
just take the [ __ ] sticker I won't
put my bag my bag
think you better not see how communion
with two of everything now it appears
you will die if I see your community
park out with both bags I want to take
one of their bag at the airport while
you're open you know take it more
[ __ ] more [ __ ] man who said that
funny money you know I think I'm back
when someone who's nothing to take a bag
like further Smith yeah with with
shout-out to um further Smith for having
me on his show on Calloway how was that
it was good bro
you always know when Mel wrote the jokes
yeah the joke man bro
oh you can hear a building before the
jokes even finish
what's up fool we just got back from
Tucson Arizona Tucson was amazing it was
hot it was just a last danger the last
deal with high water with murder it's a
blast you guys were there for less than
24 hours last night yeah we're on the
patio the show was shining on your
hardcore I'm turning into Comanches yeah
man even the Third Way a hit oh man it
was funny man like when we're flying
there's only like people who think they
could just tell me or tar one of us
where to stand and where to where to
grab stuff at the stupid ass man
like we were standing there our bags he
tried to tell Johnny Rock it could you
move to the side so he could see so I
could see my bag you know it helps
expedite everything right I looked at
the guy that said man just shut up we're
gonna move we're gonna move for you and
we are thrilled was blocked in view your
stupid hat it's not already to move [ __ ]
you
stop giving orders lieutenant man if
you're somebody just some stuff you're
somebody and somehow you don't like the
way things are going
don't try to give people orders if you
don't [ __ ] work for the airline don't
trust somebody please move no no you
move [ __ ] man what a [ __ ] idiot
huh
everybody wants to be a hall monitor I
know man I'm full of that Ronald Reagan
with no career you know like little
Sears get up and [ __ ] cheap-ass little
hat little stupid shorts carrying a big
old painting I know what's he got there
he has a Pollock I think he bought a
pool table before about a pool table
from the party always having a little
painting of the dogs I'll play poker man
everybody I know that has that photo has
know that that board has more friends
than he does was so full truth in
Arizona we got picked up by a guy named
Duke Duke of Earl big old messing him do
ya named after Duke Snider right yeah
because his father used to go to the
Dodger game bro
batting practice oh yeah but don't tell
oxycotin in Arizona because each pill is
a year in jail they're a funny man this
driver will when we get picked up at
places this is the way every driver from
every comedy closure act I think it
works for the casino so he picked us up
he said you guys need to go anywhere
Walgreen pick up a toothbrush pick up um
deodorant no okay if you need to pick up
a toothbrush after I leave call me I'll
go get it and I'll bring it to you guys
if you need anything
a broken hook or anything I mean about
by some reason unique condom that to the
show let me know ahead of time I'll go
get him and bring him back this guy was
on it man I like that [ __ ] ass fool
from the [ __ ] Denver improv take guys
I got a date with a girl okay I can't
take you to the store okay man take it
to the gas station to pick up our soda
on the way to our hotel room we have to
go to I have a date and we tried this
cat with gay all week and he knew that
we thought he was gay all week because
while soon he said I have a date I said
there you go it's a guy it's a it's a
woman guys it's a girl guys okay I've
known her for a long time let me tell
you man they have to tell me that it's a
woman it's not a woman first of all the
gay I was talking about like dinegar
Sierra he was God he's the next one guys
yeah I'm bringing him back twice of
course you have a crush on him bro
of course you bring him back you bring
him back for less slashing prices I want
one like when I get somewhere and in the
the owner or somebody tried to bring up
another Latino comedian or any other
comedian that was there and they're not
they're not like at the same level like
this guy got 100 people to show up for
free though hell yeah he's been grinding
for six months grinding hard was so full
almost broke the speaker on this so that
crack yeah man so how you been man I'm
good I seen yesterday yeah I wrestle our
little in that Hillary went up there
spoke she
reading a book you got fooled I don't
understand bro what did I got doing the
Grammys how's that gonna help anything
dawg
let it go bro let it go man you lost
yeah she he didn't win the popular vote
but he won the vote that counts electro
let it go I mean if I don't know my just
makes everybody look bad
iron fury over here I know everybody was
dressed up like like karma still never
waiting white white on the roses came in
the package huh for what no sexual
assault misconduct all that stuff right
yeah the same thing as the team time's
up me too man army to movement that they
were doing for the SAG Awards or
whatever the Golden Gloves for that full
bomb dog the host who the host James
Corden dude there's a big ol article of
a hundred and fifteen ways that James
Kaufman's not funny
Wow Britain from Britain ah there was a
tweet and I open it up but I forgot to
put it up but it's all the way from
Britain to LA to this show I do like
somebody a CBS News I read that yeah but
he's white and the British so is he safe
opened up with the Weinstein joke what a
genius you know
he party with the authentic community in
London or whatever somewhere no look
he's turning suppose he's just a
personality right an actor oh yeah I
know that he he he was on some show that
it was an Amazon let that um before his
show with another fool right yeah but I
haven't seen you watch that show a
little Britain uh it's funny dude it's
funny do I love that fact weird fool get
here and a chubby girl from that singing
yeah is it a classic British British
show from like the 80s or is a pretty
current it's very bad she would have
been a hundred now i watch one episode
let him rule i like that Inbetweeners a
second oh yeah in between coming back in
between ours is far it is - yeah
who's in that nobody you know is
hilarious what is it about about your
horny ass genius
yeah these boys is it an all-boys school
they go to
yeah but they're in like high school and
then they go into college and this is
one young do that damned if that fool
care from a private school like a real
Richie private school to go to that
little price for his family lost their
money right or something like that yeah
laughter money and um so I guess he had
to go to that food dress up all like a
little insurance like he's going to prep
school with a little bag on him right
away dog
drops him off everybody has to be his
friend because Mama's hot so every time
you see by there was a by means Joe so
there's a bunch of like a bunch of kids
trying to get laid look like a Porky's
but English but it's a series of like
four seasons babies here what hilarious
but let us put a black mirror who got
into that have any miss you know what I
did see though the Polka King funny
hilarious
I am Burger King can't believe he milked
them out of five million dollar I think
I could do that too right now I think I
could still like I think if I were to
start a Ponzi scheme with my fans they
all give me five thousand dollars each
if I tell them listen man if I tell my
fans they say man
I'm gonna start producing half hour
specials with the hottest Latino
comedians and up-and-coming comedians in
America when I need is $5,000 from 1,000
people and then with that money we're
gonna produce six specials and we're
gonna start them to HBO and I'm gonna
triple your money as investors and
producers yes and your name will be on
the credits and you'll get a free DVD
you'll be at the taping be for me but
not really it's exactly like any fund me
[Laughter]
Kickstarter used to be like when they
were trying to do it
for a certain project a positive Kino
well it's not a Ponzi scheme unless
you're promising you're guaranteeing
returns for one that's and watch paying
investors new investors
I'm sorry older investors with new
investors money that's the Ponzi scheme
the guy from the guy from Scrubs
he had a thief on me for a movie bro I
knew that's a lot of money he promised a
lot of stuff this [ __ ] got the
money and he even send a free [ __ ] to
people people are complaining I didn't
get my [ __ ] free shirt I send your
hundred dollars I didn't get my [ __ ]
button I seen you twenty bucks and I'm
not I don't think was a scam I think
that it was sloppy sloppy you know done
in a sloppy manner they didn't follow
through planning though no planning on
how they were gonna get these things out
to people for the donations you know one
thing that made me laugh in the poker
King though well his mother-in-law hated
the hell out of his ass but when those
old people came over there and talked
[ __ ] about him she threw all her food at
him because she's off a 12% return you
know you can't get that from the back
it's only to you yeah like when anyways
promising that level of return it's made
opportunity yeah promise me it's unheard
of how you doing and then when his um
the whole time his best friend was
fooling around with that she swears to
them the eighty degrees oh yeah he's
grabbing those feet okay no I couldn't
see him no more I couldn't see that
Gabby romantic after he sweated that
much he sweat it dude you sweat it
through a suit like Sawako bro the back
yeah man so what's up fool what we're
talking about man Ponzi schemes so
people get in a fire bro who got fired
everybody bought this week today
everybody bro like the way people get
fired now the people the people that
don't just get fired like before like
they don't you bring you into the room
you're fired now man how they do it now
fool is different bro like you I know
that in radio they just change the keys
on your ass oh yeah it doesn't work
anymore sometimes when our fob doesn't
work we're like Oh are we good hey
Charlie what's up fool we got ceci
Valencia si si de mamacita from Katie
and parwa nose yeah we're like my wife
she used to work at a corporate office
you know and and I was just talking
about talking about how before don't you
bring into the room and fire you but now
that though leo
when you're when you're a corporation is
different because the boss they really
have to go there and be a bad guy now
they hire in a group of executives who
are professional fire consultants to
kind of see what everybody's jobs are
and who's you know how they can make
things more efficient that's how they
first six I Drive a van a pencil
stickers fired you get paid nothing it's
not just radio that any sort of
corporation like that were they trying
to save money or they're merging radio
is the most heartbroken one because I've
heard that the keys don't worry gas
works really cutthroat because here's
the thing that makes it so cutthroat as
you never see it coming
that's the one thing about radio like
they can say hey how are you you went to
lunch with them the day before
everything was good and then all of a
sudden the key card doesn't work the
next day
yeah corporate America's cold as hell
and they don't even tire lease deals
like one I know that um our station here
in California or maybe it was or another
station in Arizona where they didn't
tell no one bro
on the whole station and the morning
there the afternoon got the night guy
once the night shift guy left everything
went to Chinese are you serious yes oh
yeah it went from a rock station to to a
Chinese and the
Chinese people came in by all the
stations and changed up the conversation
to bison station and change the sports
to all News bone bro they had all
planned our new DJ new personalities it
happens I was when I did what I do it
wild
we got bought out for wild 96:1 actually
we sold to Lackawanna and it and it
flipped formats and so they came and
pulled us all in a meeting on 3rd on a
Thursday and so we were like ok when's
the last day for us to be so we can tell
the listeners like give us our last day
and they're like oh no no your last day
was yesterday yeah and that's just what
it was
yeah like what my last day was yesterday
we didn't even know you from Compton my
family's from Compton yeah Martin Luther
King Hospital yeah a lot of people know
it as kill a king we moved around a lot
South LA so we live in and walk here we
know Santa Barbara okay man my mother
came Bulevar used to be Santa Barbara
Boulevard they change Santa Barbara to
Marcia Luther King and any Stan they
changed Brooklyn to Cesar Chavez I was
living in lemon when the 105 wasn't
there though remember that yeah the 105
wasn't there and then all of us said it
was like this room and we're like what
yeah so yeah that changed everything
what there must be a lot of traffic on
Imperial to get to the [ __ ] Airport
we said you're on my back to school
shopping at Compton indoor swap meet I
loved it
that's a popular one right yeah very
really really popular right next to
Tam's it was like down the street from
Tam's awful Long Beach Boulevard but
I've lived everywhere from like
quads to Compton to Linwood South Gate
we moved around a lot so I'd like to say
kind of like South LA is what made you
want to be a DJ we'll get into that
though I had no I I didn't want to do it
you know I was doing TV was hosting a
show we're on LA TV and LA TV at the
time was like a mtv for Latinos you know
for Bundy yes right there I was doing a
work in Latino right well they're doing
it now there but no it's not be from
anot back in the day like 15 years ago
Latino 1 oh yeah Cruz Paul Saucedo back
in the day and I said something about
being from the IE on one of my segments
and I caught the ear of a program
director out there and the IE and they
hired me over the phone yeah it was
actually kind of cool and fast forward
this year's my 16th year now in radio
Wow yeah it's crazy cuz the first three
weeks I was like oh I could do this and
then I was like oh I don't like this
this sucks and I went in and I gave them
my my letter of resignation and I said
thank you I appreciate it I'm gonna go
ahead and concentrate on LA TV you know
thank you for the opportunity they're
like no wait a minute they're like we
think you got something there try it out
for six months and if six months you
don't like it then give us your letter
of resignation 16 years later Here I am
major rays you passed on the opportunity
and they still they still yeah they
still want to be here and they didn't
want to let me go which is kind of cool
because now like I love it it's been 16
years and I work on K Day and power and
it's just crazy to legendary stations
you know here in Los Angeles
you turn on Katy Perry power I can't I
started on Katy love Katy Katy it was my
dream job has always been my dream job
as a radio personality
growing up in LA I grew up on the NWA's
and the ice cubes and the dr. Dre's and
the pox
uncle jams army hey man you already know
and so I loved it but this year well a
little bit of last year the end of last
year and this year they started playing
with me on you know hey let's have you
fill in on power and that's what I'm
doing right now so I'm doing the Cruz
show on power 106 how did what happened
well how did power and Katie get
together we're owned by a company called
Murillo yeah it's always been owned by
the same people know we we Katie was on
his own by Murillo media and I want to
say like maybe in the beginning of last
year it was rumors that power was up for
sale and so our company ended up
purchasing power and they decided to
move us all in the same building and
that's where wit from there and it's
been good because now you have an
old-school iconic station which Katie
was the first radio station in the world
before any other radio station in the
world so we would have like the other
stations because of cadence you have an
iconic legendary station as Katie
you've got an iconic la station like
power 106 oh it was it's a good luck
kiddo were the first Asian and we're in
hip-hop hip-hop hip-hop am 1515 8:00
a.m. that was when I'm that guy to come
on and do the spores which reals it
could be the game in which Rios
I don't know what was which world was we
had a guy I used to love the guy States
which rules reals I know that on power
on power on um Howard Stern used carts
what did you say when she reads when she
read the news oh well she says like
benign coded but they're using they were
used to use old car oh she talks she
says I'm allowed benign yeah yeah yeah
because she's reading it they're gonna
play it she's telling somebody to play
it it's probably like a key for you you
gotta learn when you get there yet no no
you can learn you know what I say you
learn when you get there because every
station uses different products and and
just different equipment so when we went
from Katie and we moved in to the same
building as power we adapted their
program but we didn't use that at Katie
so they had to do a whole training for
all Katie people to get used to the new
equipment so it's just different for
different stations so the board that's
something you learn on your own
no well we trained I'm I am the best I
loved it when I saw her you and I we did
something without promoting my HBO
special and I saw you like cutting that
shift bad like I'll take care of all
this yeah that [ __ ] Itzik skills man
know how you do that [ __ ] I don't even
know how anybody do another when Big
Dawg went to kiss a famine Sacramento he
did not want to learn how to do that
[ __ ] give me an engineer bro yeah you
know when you want engineers but I'm
good I want to do my own I want to work
my own board I want to do my own edits
yeah what the sound is in my head what I
want it to be like already so I love
doing my own board work I don't I don't
know I can't I can't trust anybody else
to help me run my show or to really
depend on them too much you know I I get
it you don't say but I'm just such a
hand see and I would want to sit there
and be like let me see what you do like
I love all that eight-part Kathy he's a
savage there your favorite day he's done
it dumbing up it's a minute there we go
yes so that's what you do that's
something you wanna do is just cuz I
know you grew up with you grew up with
Snoop Dogg in there
what group listening to Snoop Dogg my
boyfriend actually works for snoop we're
around a lot but we did know I grew up
listening all them and I work with them
closely you know I can I can sit there
I'm in a movie coming out with a tradie
from the East Siders and Mike Epps
I just did I'm a hologram it's really
common today with a movie I don't know
say right now I can't say too much about
it but it is coming in if there's okay
Bruce
[Laughter]
make sure you guys check it out it's
coming out soon it is a it's a it's a
short film but my guess is hella funny
in it oh my god is so great funny yeah
so the fact that did you meet manager TC
no no no I didn't I didn't I actually
got called in through trade II from the
East Siders was a really good friend of
mine made his wife are good friends as
well but the fact that I grew up to
these people when I was listening to the
music I'm very West Coast I love Callie
I don't want to go anywhere else and now
I get to call them friends it's really
awesome for me but it's just a test to
like the passion that I have for that
culture how did you get the movie the
hologram role he just called me well I
was just called and was like Cece I need
you to do me a solid and I was like I
got you let's do it and they sent me the
script I got the script read over it and
went in there and killed it my tabs know
you um it knows probably of me you know
me through interviews I'm not as close
with Mike as I am with tradie
oh I got the call from tradie
so the best gigs man when you're not
enough to audition and somebody knows
your work oh you know what cost se
that's all I'll get most of my work is
it really you just look at the phone
you're like people pick up the phone and
call me I'd be like listen Philly but we
need you real global you know when a guy
who look like a maintenance guy today I
want to go read for a maintenance guy
like a handyman for a for a Shawnee flix
I can see it you know cuz I might not
get it so who cares it's all for Run DMC
run it's a project for running oh so do
I get to be the handyman and when I get
there
everybody there live like a [ __ ]
handyman but I'm the only one that lives
like an incompetent one they want it cuz
man whatever we're talking about I had
to look it up I don't know what grout
work was bro I know what grout work is
yeah I had to look I had no idea so when
I flicked when I kept reading it on over
I don't know what it was they never
really liked what it was okay I mean
what damages graduated from here yeah
graduated from poly high school probably
yes
you know what my mom had to move outside
of LA cuz at some point she was a single
parent
we just started you know she had two
girls we started being bad banging but I
was chicken out and glue you know I'm
saying trying to go to like all like the
rave parties and stuff I'm shooting up
moving over a bear then oh yeah poly
bear I graduated though that was dope oh
yeah I'm Nerissa
good okay okay all right notice I don't
have no problems with Nord Avista we're
good no but I ended up doing that and
then I had been doing radio all the way
from wild you know from the IE to Vegas
to now LA and you know I even worked for
Jennifer Lopez that was awesome doing
the collective on Nouveau TV so I loved
the fact that I got to do that and then
I voice I did play a gangbanger and
grand theft auto five
from the yeah from the family's gang I
was from the family's gang awesome
oh well he's probably heard me say move
out the way [ __ ] the big fan of
anybody hurt on that game yeah
oh man that's crazy did you get to write
on the show just be a voiceover no no I
was just a voiceover what they do is
they don't tell you which game - they
don't I didn't go in there knowing it
was for grand theft auto 5 I knew it was
for a particular game but they were real
hush-hush about it and they give you a
picture of the character and then they
give you the line so you can kind of get
in character but it was funny because
the character was a black gangbang like
a black girl was a gangbanger cornrows
sounds like you good thank you sure and
they're like can you do it I was like I
can do it let's do it they're like
alright so I went in and Nell did and
then I knew though the way I was reading
I was like I think this might be granted
bottom I think this might be Grand Theft
Auto and then it comes out and it was it
was so dope yeah I remember I'm I think
I'm DJ pool was I'm doing an interview
underneath with on power in the morning
he was talking about grand theft auto
san andreas San Andreas and he wrote on
it you wrote the story lines for other
who's dope I mean I was like what
here's a guy who wrote Friday was Ice
Cube and after Friday liked him so much
that he was writing grand theft auto san
andreas he wrote that all the lines for
all the gangsters
we're in green yeah that's Joe I love DJ
booth oh look at your job like that man
Felipe go write funny line for this
character okay what you were saying
would you love to write for though
anybody man who would be great though
got the vowel yeah I'll write line for
criminals you piece of [ __ ] I'll be a
bison I go you're nothing now that way I
will play man I'm not good at graphic
auto only the Bison would two minutes in
bro I've become a serial killer on that
show and on that game night I get tired
I don't wanna ride a car I get in my car
I start [ __ ] shooting random pee
I want a killing spree and if you go on
a killing spree on Grand Theft Auto
rather you start getting a red light
like people start noticing anyway so you
killed ten people the whole world after
you're a dog he's wrong I'm a fugitive
so man I'm not getting away from them
how do I come to chasing me the police
are chasing me I get on a boat the
[ __ ] coast guards are chasing me
I just drowned bro damn your true nature
comes out as a faithful DJ the other
chance you're eager GRU a Dijon no you
know everybody's dead oh yeah all of a
sudden everybody's in a vinyl huh are
you gonna do is ya now everybody's
environment so crazy but before was like
just buy a laptop and you're a DJ ya
know everybody's a member of your new
music bro holler at me how many till you
get hit up a bro
sensitive you know anybody wants to buy
some beats
hey I know people that leave out their
beats
yeah they loose that like if you you got
a beat and maybe somebody's like hey
Dawg like I only got like 150 I am
alesis out you so you could use it but
I'm at least it out to like five other
different people too like people do that
now it's crazy
franchising does their least about their
beats I know people lease other jokes
ain't nobody gettin paid I in your
comedian that will prepare another
comedian for the weekend to do the jokes
yeah at least he was honest though right
I keep my pits on once ain't no oh man
so I'm whoa did you met what was one of
the most memorable interviews you had to
be fans Felipe Esparza oh you are the
most memorable you were the most
down-to-earth you're like will you sit
him down and you see me you were
captivated by saying you know what this
is what I do with radio to interview
people like this like you yes
inspirational you know the one thing
that I do love about you that we still
talk about to this day is that you had
said something during the interview
where I think you said you mentioned
where you paid for your own catering and
you had like your credits roll up and it
was you and it was so dope because it
was
a real moment where we're like man we've
all done that at some point in our lives
with our projects but you were you know
you came out in your forthcoming with it
yeah man and I got excited looking
Philippe as far as the catering do you
were in the show exactly uh you know
what going back to that I I've
interviewed a lot of people I was one of
the first people to interview Chris
Brown and I remember when he first came
in he was young like 40-plus - huh no no
he's a sweetheart
he had an umbrella huh no he was 14 14
yeah and I remember came with his mom
and the program director at the time was
like CC I really need you to do me this
favor
his record rep is a friend of mine just
please interview this kid his name is
Chris Brown he's new and I was so mad
and I was like why they gave me all
these up-and-coming nobody's ever heard
of like I want the solid ones like you
can I was pointing to the afternoon
radio person I'm like you give him all
the good interviews you giving me all
you know to me the new ones I
interviewed him did my thing and then
like two weeks later I've seen him on
MTV and I'm like hey welcome I was like
that's the kid that I just interviewed
two weeks ago and then it was Chris
Brown it's just crazy when things like
that happen Jennifer Lopez when I
started working for her she actually
heard me on the radio I was on the
Latino at the time and I was arguing
with my co-host named tattoo and I said
with a shag rug yeah
uh-huh it's not there anymore you got it
removed yeah but um yeah me and him were
arguing and she heard she heard me and
she told her personal assistant find out
who that girl is and I need a girl like
that on my on my team working there you
know to me for a while and it was dope
and I loved it and so little moments
like that are so real and I think what
makes it worthwhile it's not really
interviewing the celebrities per se what
makes my job worthwhile is when I meet
listeners and I hear listeners saying
man you changed my life or man I listen
to you every single morning or what you
said really touched me that's what makes
this worth doing wow man that's good you
inspire people like that because I
inspire people to go shoot themselves
damn grand theft auto doc I inspire
people to leave their boyfriends after
18 years I do a joke where I see how
many boyfriend and girlfriend right here
and then somebody was
me how many years 12 ugh you ain't the
one [ __ ]
oh right everybody well I did that joke
last year and at the Nova Theatre I'm
there March 23rd shameless plug a woman
have been married a boyfriend/girlfriend
with a guy 17 years and I kept ragging
on him bro you don't marry her long
story short he hits me up two weeks ago
what an eBay bro I had an awesome time
on your short man man
you I was a guy you're making fun of for
being married boyfriend girl for 17
years guess were they
I guess top that show the wake-up call
for my lady a cuz she left me to eat
lady had a good time are you serious
serious damn breakups happen at the
Phillippe Esparza I thought what you
called at the at the arm at the the last
show I did I ran into a couple I was
going to my room I said hello that lady
she looked like Miley Cyrus at 40 Oh
Lord and she had the same hair too and
she was there was a dark for some
Mexican food like me crazy food name of
rain I was here name and we're doing
meeting greeting on April you want to
get a little auntie homes
he goes he crazy homes and then um no
I'm good
the next morning we're at the buffet and
I run into her the girl uh-huh as usual
what happened was your husband oh and
she's a white girl but the way she
stated me made it sounds so real she
said what happened like that oh my
husband he comes out this Madhuri I took
I see no it was another this mother a in
the hotel room we haven't seen him no
we're gonna leave now and hopefully
he'll make it back home do you have
she's gonna leave her husband like that
out there what are you gonna do he can't
find him yes he's gone he took up with a
car he went to go get he wasn't gonna do
what he's gonna do
get low quality oh man look cocktail I
mean this guy must be up somewhere man I
got to a fire with the cactus
he probably was the heaviest thing with
a javelina
that's too much you'll get those story
from people or man you inspired me to
get a job you know what I do I get those
ones that well no you just keep me going
thank you you gave me through the
morning you know yeah I do a lot I get
those a lot you get me through the
morning laughs in the morning man I
think we have like the best job really
ever because we don't have to be so
serious no no the world is such a
serious place right now and it is a
hurting world but we get to make people
laugh we get to have fun we get we have
the fun side of the entertainment so I
think it is a blessing morning is the
front sight morning radio good afternoon
it's Jeff like morning radio everybody
like like you gotta be on give the other
person a ssin of you being bummed out
from how the house you know there was no
more weed I guess the problem for you I
guess but whatever those doors like a
drama or but in the morning you can show
that huh no no no wake up huh yeah are
you doing oh no I don't know how I do it
I can't explain it like everybody is
like see see you wake up like that I'm
like I don't know what it is I just have
it I don't need to drink coffee I drink
decaf crazy because and they're funny
cuz everybody's like you drink decaf and
I'm like oh my god you see the energy I
have had caffeine I'd be through the
roof so I don't know I just have this
energy and I'm literally up but I also
wake up at 3 o'clock in the morning and
I'm ready to perform by 6:00 I've
already had yeah I have a couple hours
already to get it in you know to me wow
pause oh no no I say by the time you get
home you start kicking [ __ ] and all
pissed off ok the only time you see me
where if I'm kind of quiet and I get
grouchy I get quiet
I'll get quiet and then you'll say
you'll notice something's wrong cuz I'm
not talking as much but
I have a lot of energy it's really
freaking crazy I don't get it
wow man I don't know I don't know what
it is to not have it I don't when I see
people struggling I'm like where why
because it I don't I don't know I just
don't struggle three o'clock to get up
to be there at 6:00 bye bro morning guy
morning radio guys you know like I know
bro what little different now man and
not even have you got a thankfully but
there's cameras all on point kinda yeah
before you go in bro do radio and rock
station with a chick Oh school mornings
[Music]
she has her shoes off she has signed
those on and I bet you radio station
with a girl is pretty but she don't look
pretty - everybody up but me I know
pretty she's wearing her pajamas bro
pajamas gloves glasses you know looking
like Adrian from Rocky Wow
now is different now it's totally
different
I see I've been to Fox radio in Miami
and I'm that lady now she puts on makeup
now before she never put on makeup
really and she's an older woman but now
she puts on makeup she looks good cuz
there's a selfie coming yeah it's
important yeah and they want to know all
the shots so yeah definitely it takes me
two hours like I get up at 3:00 and I'm
ready to go by like 5:15 I'm straight
but you have to look like per fear to
look presentable now right yeah
absolutely can't be looking like a rock
station anymore huh you look good
there's it's just now it's like social
media has integrated so much with radio
it's all about you know I mean like you
said the selfies that the instant snaps
instagrams you got so much that it's not
just radio you're the new generation of
radio man the old generation man you get
ugly [ __ ] bro like roadies huh
they were
when they will tell you you have a face
for radio you knew you're ugly yeah
they'll say that sometimes for like
you'll hear people say oh yeah they have
a face for radio and it's like not
anymore anymore boy now yeah you never
see Ryan Seacrest exactly exactly yeah
the girls are looking like Telemundo you
know I mean whether women and stuff I
know it's the only real station I see
legs
oh man radios a good time though
it is yeah man you it was like
late-night radio though yeah you later
hello anybody listening and Lois two in
the morning which I did 7:00 p.m. to 12
midnight in Vegas but that was an
exception to the rule cuz Vegas is
24-hour City yes so but it was funny
because at one point I had applied for a
night job out here in Cali and I got
towed quite frankly to my face that if I
was a guy would have got it already but
because I was a female nobody wants to
hear a female at night on a hip-hop show
I said okay so I ended up going to Vegas
and I landed the night show I was the
first female radio personality to be on
at night and I was number one in Vegas
and top five in the country and that was
my big fu to them you know but yeah I
loved it I loved doing nights nights is
different you get all the crazy people
at night you don't know him especially
in Vegas man we were right off the strip
right off the strip so we got all like
all the people that were just witted
they were with it and about it how old
was this guy who said nobody walked to
her woman Natalie and I when I when I
was calling nine seven six late at night
I want to hear a woman one late at night
driving around here a criminal voyeurism
on my seat down here
[Music]
method are stickers the Vani know you
know what I did I actually had one it
was so weird it was random it wasn't
even like he was such a stalker but it
was a weird stalker like he wasn't even
in love with me type of stalker he was
obsessed with just wanting to be around
me so like just talking he he would
steal all the photos for my website
lingering and we had to pull down my
website because of him really yeah and
he would distribute my pictures to like
his co-workers and stuff through email
and be like my sister's on the radio and
so he made the whole lie that I was a
sister that I was Dominican and that I
was from New York and that we lived in
an orphanage but what was really scary
was he started having creditors call
because he was using me as a reference
so I started calling the station yeah
[Laughter]
coworkers they got they actually put you
know two and two together and they
called me warned me because they said we
think he's unstable and he keeps yeah
radio station was gonna put a you know
they were gonna give me a restraining
order yeah we didn't we didn't end up
doing that I just ended up for like the
like next six months getting escorted to
it like some of my events and stuff just
to be aware but I've gotten some crazy
people
yeah yes we'll work it in somewhere in
West Covina somewhere in West Covina
yeah they made that planet up perfectly
he had like an apartment complex called
to like I was his reference on
everything in his mind he truly believed
I was his sister it's the craziest thing
yeah and I'm not Dominican I'm Mexican
like George Costanza said man it's not a
lie if you believe it the real poker key
nobody ain't cosign for anybody it's
crazy crazy man yeah and then I got a
girl one time that was fascinated
fascinated with she if we were at a club
and I was hosting but I host this one
club every Saturday night for two years
I would host it okay it was called
Cheers in Moreno Valley that's why I
started dirty Collins
named cookie used to run that club okay
so I was hosting there when I was wild
96 and um there was a girl there and I
guess one night she just got drunk she
should've kissed me and I end up
slapping her in her face you walk in has
that ruined that has that bathroom to
the little everything would go down in
the back room yeah yeah the owner was
like a middle-eastern yeah are the walls
white there yeah that one was called
something Beach like two exits uh-oh
uncle Marino Beach Drive I want to yeah
dude I remember that when I forgot what
it's something a beach oh man that
changed name like three or four times
they have radio I do remember that one -
that you're talking about Philly but the
one we're talking about was off of the
16 pigeon pasture oh yeah right to the
left
this year's lady right across the street
from in and out yes across the street
but I remember I was like she I just saw
like her trying to come towards me and I
freaked out and I just slapped her in
the face
yeah and that's from listening to you on
radio yeah and then stalking you at
those at me it was weird and she caught
it was so gross coming her butterfly
that was the weirdest thing ever
she was a bit okay I think there was
another club out of Moreno Valley or
Hesperia that was owned by Egyptians was
that tab daddy's I was tapped out
they're all Egyptian guys yeah it was so
huge like ya know real nice guys okay I
got kicked out of there I just got them
there because that other club got shot
up a notch here's the other one that
would they change the name after that
but that's the one that has palm trees
in the club and then like on the stage
there's palm trees with the name
something be Jeff I forgot I'm so mad
back in lo de Maria Novella trying to
make it happen with the clubs popping
cuz a lot of people from LA went to
Moreno of it yes and I love you that guy
kicked
lnto rumors I think that was tremors no
travelers the beach or Margaritaville
that's what it's called margarita beats
what was called yeah see we all know the
club scene remember though let me throw
it back Riverside Club Metro yeah people
just getting blasted on cuz I feels like
there was a Mexican in here and then
those westside pjc he's like it was a
lot of [ __ ] happening what it was what
shoe they had a room so like they had
these multiple rooms one was a hip-hop
one was deep house one was rock Rose
rockiness fun you'll see a different
types of people that was born when the
clothes were doing that because they
changed everything before it was just
one scene but it was cool like to go to
like a hidden door and there was all
hip-hop oh yeah they were story was like
a good talker he goes to another plane a
bunch of our posers that door rocking
upon your you're on that cement or do
talking about it when when everybody's
telling everybody was starting up crews
particles after were life you know when
I was in high school we had party crews
true but I wasn't one of them but it was
a bunch of them right and I know that
I'm the [ __ ] I'm the guy - Carlito
from Easter the river his mom was in a
crew called dreamers and it was five
chicks and they returned they will show
up to a party everybody all the dreamers
are you another chick that were younger
than them they were my age they were
called the ladies of no return it was
like that song and then like they were
pass by and my friend baby James
will say nobody wants y'all your [ __ ]
back anyways
man so at a party cruise what what did
those people who had a party crew do did
they promote the party they invited we
would throw a party you would charge no
charge like the people will like it
maybe in some time there was a small
party crew no puns don't have a house
party and one of the friends with the
biggest house nobody's there like no
move all the furniture out and your part
in the living room but if you're like a
party crew like big party crew like
Teddy Boys you know or those guys in the
bullet was Alfonso name called negotiate
goes to eat huge negocio Inc they had
the money to hire a DJ to rent a house
the club near the power1 don't bother
ones and they had a comedy night at rose
meat and they go co inc and the guy was
just like oh yeah man their money yeah I
don't yeah we didn't we weren't the
ballers we would throw the parties and
be like five dollars you know and then I
was cheap man I'm one of the house party
in the projects one dollar to get in but
if you had good record where that you
were free my friend baby James repos was
down by the door and he was a DJ he goes
you know because I thought we'd get in
alright have a daughter oh my god come
on you owe your money on your old album
man she got some Ohio players bring that
[ __ ] over here we're gonna mix that [ __ ]
- oh hi players hey what about the hop
though you just taking me back you know
I love the hops out the only place where
you could hook up with a mom and a
daughter the point that one's gone right
yeah like would still there hey queer
boy over there man you don't just fight
mess can you find some moments every
time you should go to the Lakewood hop
at the end of the night Greg Townsend
would always show up yeah we don't
remember that Raiders really oh he won't
show up with his big old Superbowl ring
from 1983 and rest it on chip both head
[Laughter]
yeah man the heart
with my [ __ ] man that's my joke I was
like 2 or 3 times man
is that the hop in the song mohab yeah
the Righteous Brothers yeah I wouldn't
know about the Righteous Brothers sorry
had the time of my oh I know that song
good you lost that lovin feeling there
you go did you guys see the Grammys last
night I did like the lowest-rated we
were just we were talking about it over
there earlier this morning we're talking
about how Kendrick didn't get album of
the year it was brutal Mars yeah so
we're just but they were saying it was
the lowest watched ever horrible ass
performances right you know there's some
of them were just kind of boring but do
they live seeing with alive oh there
were some that was that was kind of live
huh like Rihanna Rihanna did her thing
shut up to Rihanna she did her thing how
you met her I know I haven't been able
to meet her I love Rihanna though I
would love to meet her though no but it
was cool it was just you know what I
know now I have to watch the Grammys I
fast forward you know I mean like you
know DVR it watch it then and then you
just fast-forward through the others
that you don't want yeah Lisa and I we
turn the TV on to the Grammys that knows
of a BAM plane that we never heard and
we right away we change the channel yeah
I don't even know who was like a country
band there's a horrible man well they
asked cardi B I guess on the red carpet
if she was excited or something she was
like yeah she's like I got butterflies
in my stomach and in my vagina okay I
want me to warm your room unless I want
me a Caesar salad with Roman lettuce
right I was funny I saw a video of her
talking about how they messed up her
seed her salad and she said I'm they
messed up my Caesar salad it will have
man names on it I want to see the salad
the way the Romans ate it with Roman
salad
and so men give it to you how the Puerto
Ricans eat about that yeah I don't see
how somebody like Bruno Mars can win for
that album when that album was such an
like an homage to older music you know
was all super influenced but you know
sting and Maura stay at the time and
like all those songs that he had on that
album were kind of derivative you know
of that kind of music but man throwback
yeah more beyond the throwback like am i
listening to new vocals right it's
strong enough to where they had to have
sting on his performance last year or
whatever whenever he did that big
performance like he pulls sting out
because it sounds like a police who a
new artist oh my god I just had it
Alyssa Alyssa Cara which is kind of mad
we were kind of second one it says it'll
win she sings Tijuana deported to
Tijuana I can't eat her tamale not a
song believe it
Camila Camila BIA yes she had a
beautiful speech by the way last night
so it was kind of dope but I just was
like well the speech about being a being
latina and standing on that stage and
you know bina she's from you know her
parents are immigrants and she's like
you know what was she bit like Mexican
and Cuban or Mexican Porter something
like yeah and and she was just very
proud to stand there and it just felt
dope as a Latina that we're like yo
you're on that stage you represent all
of us at that one point hell yeah yeah
let you do something bad then we don't
know you hey pal got best comedy album I
was the coolest part I didn't get
nominee
[Applause]
we need new people on the board
yes sir though we're calling it no I
think he might even host next year
because I mean come on he practically
co-hosted this year James Corden yeah it
was I think Dave Chappelle did his thing
but yeah he did win Best Comedy album of
the year I think half the people
watching the Grammys probably don't know
who damn coordinates yeah nobody and out
lay growing up we used to watch his
channel - that's no charity to come out
the worse on my television cable I'll
tell you right now you could throw your
TV out the window busted open from the
back plug it in and Telemundo still
coming telemundo is the best looking
channel even if you break your
television you break your television
you'll never see CBS and NBC ever again
you need a [ __ ] super antenna for
that movie like what when I wasn't last
comic standing that's when I said I'm
gonna be a channel 4 channel 4 we never
watched that shadow we never watched
channel 2 growing up we grew up in a
project so you can't have no big on 10
on a freeway on a [ __ ] roof so
channel 2 with one channel that never
looked good on my TV channel 9 and
Telemundo we're perfect and 11 - because
it was kind of little hood sometimes 11
man we want to see cops so um you ever
worried at the red carpet is that
something you like to do like just that
out there talk to people before I love
red carpets I do a lot of red carpets
yeah red carpets are really crazy I mean
I think it's different for you Philly
because you get to walk the red carpets
you know for us we're on the other side
so we're fighting for the interviews and
it's weird cuz if you noticed pay
attention all the artists will walk kind
of fast and they're like hey hey you're
like no no what I need I need to ask you
a question so it's a little bit more
savage doing a work in the red carpets I
love it though I
off on that like we were on the red
carpet with Veronica at the arms
Veronica supersonic and we were at the
one for our den of thieves Dana I wasn't
invited at that one we were too long
well baby get director of lining that
morning how no really how is it cuz I
got to interview O'Shea Jackson jr. and
of course Pablo Schreiber that planned
in a thesis but I haven't seen it yet
but when I interview to miss out like
they're talking about is Joe but I'm
like okay if I would have saw that movie
when I was 14 years old
Dana thieve I was probably I saw 10 ft
even I was 14 or 15 years old I probably
would have thought that was the [ __ ]
best movie I've ever seen because a lot
of shooting I don't [ __ ] shooting
it's like oh my god like that he's like
heat with a with a worse grip you know
what I mean but as an older man you know
who's seen a bunch of movies let that
you know for dogs the dogs in heat you
know the bank-robbery movies but then
you watch that movie you know I'm too
old party to watch a movie out there
because I know that when I see I know I
can see ok that piece is from heat that
line was from shaft you know it took 14
years to make get out of here OSHA OSHA
jackson started that way when he was 8
so another 22 we get to enclose the
movie but I'll say this the movie has a
very good surprise ending where that
would that makes it look that this will
be a part two which I hope there isn't
yeah it's good man it's oh you never
knew is gonna end like that but also man
is like in like come on man you really
you cannot break into the Federal
Reserve and get away with it
yeah that's true too right you go to JFK
right I feel bad because when they came
in they hyped it up so much that I was
like left that interview like me
watch this movie this movies about to be
sick and then Philebus bars is like what
long no CC don't go what do I keep
saying let's go to the movies it's man
that movie like the movie was all shot
it's all based in Hawthorne in Los
Angeles but if you've been running the
word on la la la you know that that
movie The Shining a bay a chase scene I
don't know you've been in Oakland or
you've been Oakland yeah
and with that brace on top it is the 105
that's the [ __ ] never the [ __ ] um
no 808 and I knew right they were nerds
driving at that Berkeley bro it was like
I call this telling me in heart Lord
yeah tell me no Chavez Harbor area and
not show up imc bunch of dead of Isis
what they supposed to be protesting the
Oscars
well the Grammys just passed maybe the
Oscars coming up shortly yeah yeah
somebody there was a teen approach to
the Grammys yeah it just was very I just
don't think there was enough
representation there they get relegated
to the Latin Grammys that's true that
but even that you know the submission
for Latin Grammys and I don't know not
American Grammys but English speaking
their submission is the same and there
is no difference to them internally
between the two but they have two
separate shows and two separate okay
Mike how many I'll be nominated for
that's of gravity well it was banished
for that that's the thing are you yeah
maybe so but what if you are a Spanish
person
in English to put you in a Latin Grammys
like Jennifer Love with a regular
Grammys or she's been on both she's been
nominated for them both Suavecito
Suavecito was like that's old-school
yeah I remember that back a little touch
of that that's the one I that's the only
one I know that the other one or two
there's two t of us yeah yeah the
brother broke up what was the drama
behind that I wish I knew no no there's
two wars there's a war the bad war with
Lonnie right there's no writer yeah that
was a little confusing cuz I saw that
too like on a fiery yeah low rider is
the actual band I used to play behind
Lonnie from war mm-hmm
so but I think Laura is a horrible name
if you're gonna be an extra war band
your name should have been called Cisco
Kid then everybody knows Oh Cisco Kid
that's not [ __ ] different war but
with the deal they have lowrider cannot
pronounce or ever saying that they were
from war on radio stations you can say
real form though though the guys
informally for war lowrider nanana
nanana about slipping into war no you
cannot mention war at all you can't even
mention the guy who don't like Lonnie
damn there's a major beef right there's
a major yes I may not want to touch that
yeah man
because I have to be known as the guy
formerly Otto for the guy who formerly
used to open up or fluffy the two
Gallagher's on the brother whoa [ __ ]
with that
Gallagher I can't sold his act to his
twin brother or her brother yeah he was
called Gallagher to shut up yeah
Siri had a suitor get his name back to
be the original back Gallagher yeah
because other brother smashes burritos
he smashes I'm food with a little chip
what did she like that's crazy
in the dead to the side of the brother
do he did
oh yeah there's majorie that Christmas
dinner is just really awkward over there
yeah right now in a Philippine there's a
girl just like you call himself sassy
yeah the Filipino laddie
hey man if she's making some money I
need some I need my bro did you ever
work with that guy hey does this deal
right here in the morning do you think
that [ __ ] was black too
yes I did he had me fooled I bet yeah I
used to listen to here only because I
like the voice and that's the kind of
boy you need for late nights 92.3 the
beat no color lines okay not have to
point through the media to your man
field and we're gonna slow it down right
now with Ohio player 2 you know where
that turn on that hot water light that
candle makes a guest appearance on
Moishe yes and that's what everybody was
like do is Asian oh my god we thought he
was black I thought I don't know he was
a Bobby Lee character yeah because Edwin
used to do the stealing okay I don't
know I thought he was like Asian like
yeah maybe Korean or something that is
ya know but he had a great voice and I
don't know where he's that anymore you
see that a lot coming up a Raider like a
Percy and pretend to be a black woman or
doing like a bicycle boys you know I got
a call from Ike actually got a call from
Philadelphia back like almost like nine
years ago and they wanted me to do radio
out there and they offered me a
substantial
amount of money to go to radio out there
but the only concern with them was we
need you to sound more urban so I said
well what's urban my family grew up in
Compton from Lynnwood watts I was like
you don't get as urban as me so what are
you talking about more urban they're
like well you know we just need you to
be just a little bit more you know the
city's more urban I see you need me to
be more black is that what you're saying
black you can say black and they're like
what yeah and I said I'm not I said I'm
a Latina I'm from South LA but if you
want if somebody to sound black you
might want to go ahead and hire a black
Raider personality that might be your
easiest joy the light as we find and I
couldn't do it though
it would have ruined my career why if
listeners were to saw me they would have
they would have thought I was a sellout
or that I was faking the funk yeah and
it really would have messed up my career
so I had to decline it and I did
actually refer them to a really dope
african-american rate of person that
kills it yeah no they didn't it was
crazy because she's she was awesome but
yeah they've asked me to be different
ways I remember - believe it or not I
got a the same person that actually told
me that they didn't want me at night it
was like hey CeCe you know the listeners
love you they think you're awesome they
relate to you you know and in the sense
of you know your personality your
feistiness but you know what's there our
listeners are Latinas and you have no
kids so we were one dream and here's the
the stupid part you know radio is just
about acting it's smoking me or so with
that being said well let's build your
character as a single parent but I don't
have any kids so what are you talking
about top line what's gonna happen when
I'm in the community and they're asking
me about my child that I'm talking about
on the radio and I don't have one and so
they were trying to cope with that and
I'm like I'm not doing it I'm not doing
it and I went home and I told my mom I
think I'm gonna get fired because I
refuse to be anybody other than I am and
they ended up letting it go away but you
know they did ask me they wanted me to
pretend that I was a single parent I
didn't have any kids I said no to that I
put my foot down and then I years ago I
got asked to be you know cici your your
character on radio is the home girl and
people love you but I would like you to
be the type of girl how do I put it you
want F a guy unless he drives a Mercedes
Benz or BMW that's kind of grinded
and I was like oh so you want to ruin my
radio career because I Drive a Nissan
Versa like there's just no way it's not
it's not happy yeah it really is what it
is I'm not gonna do it if I can't afford
a Mercedes Benz or a BMW I'm gonna hold
somebody else to that like it's not
gonna happen and I fought again for
three days went back home told my mom I
might get fired because I'm gonna stand
and what I believe in and later on they
they said we'll just let you do you and
a year later the same person apologized
for me tomorrow and was like you know
what I'm sorry I did that I know now
that that was a good move that we didn't
go that route that crazy that would be
crazy
you were took that job in Philadelphia
you've been this deer right here deer
right here and you know I'm just telling
him junior shut up got my baby over here
sleeping under the bed maybe I'll sleep
in the DJ booth messed up you say that
they want you at black and I'm trying to
think right now the last black female DJ
in our lane I can't even bigger one
I'm sure strawberry Pat Prescott still
in LA
give me some funny some names yeah sure
sure Shirley strawberry was she did I
think it was 92.3 the beat with Steve
Harvey and she did the strawberry letter
I remember that and then then it became
like I remember at one point it was like
100.3 jams or something I don't know if
you guys remember something like that
mega 100.3 yeah maybe yeah Wow right
maybe before hilburn Esquivel right but
I think those two those are the ones
that I kind of grew up on was Pat
Prescott and and with Shirley Shirley
strawberry and then then you had like
your Michelle visage not academic Roos I
grew up on her she's still at cage L age
and she's half black half Puerto Rican
and half Jamaican so yeah and right now
it's a lot of Latinas
all I know is um yeah you're coaching
her with more secretary yonkos one or
two point margaritas there for 25 years
oh here they are Lobo for oh why people
know furrows Mike secular readings I
cannot believe you even said that I
should come up with so many jokes about
him he'll start off that day well I will
leave it to the coast
yeah right now we got Barbara coasting
in Ventura County and and when she wants
to give a message to John who was
coasting right now in Virginia and I
would all stop and go coasting the
muhfuckas cheetah or Virginia thing that
you want to UM she was the cause with um
you make me feel like a natural woman
mark secular radio we have art LeBeau
cuz that cause one two three everybody's
coasting everybody [ __ ] over there
around cleaning in or locked up or
locked up yeah
shut up for Folsom's you know I even
know I wonder if audible knows how many
hits he [ __ ] put out on the radio a
lot of messages were hits because
something little to it messages it's not
like someone's gonna get shot right now
in Compton yeah we have a listener right
here Snoopy to to killer from from South
Central a teen with a bullet yeah what
yeah we shout out shout out to a killer
out there in Tehachapi message from from
Folsom from Snoopy gee canola in
south-central [ __ ] our Lobo you've
been a [ __ ] reading Spanish names for
forty years
can you pronounce one right [ __ ]
our limo is like I think he's like 96
years older so he can you pronounce
words we get we got robbery
he's in his 90s I know if Ben Scully can
pronounce a [ __ ] Spanish name so
could you this guy you know I was gonna
be like Ella and then I'm out of balance
balance Ella Valenzuela yeah Rodriguez
loved it though I gotta say [ __ ] on
every Sunday still yeah she's on every
Sunday and he still does all his
concerts so yeah he's doing a radio in a
at the drive-in
yeah back I think I want to say like in
the 40s or 50s and now I want to read
that book I'm dying up here that's kind
of a comedy movie movie he used to own
the comedy store before with the comedy
stores here yeah I never see rose he
owned it and I'm doing when I'm he's to
lease it to the Mitzi shore and now why
the comedy store was in his heyday in
the 80s it was making a lot of money
they were trying to buy that buy it off
him and he don't wanna sell and they
finally police they buy it off him oh
that's crazy
he owned the whole [ __ ] the whole Comedy
Store ah damn that's crazy I didn't know
that and I can go back because you know
we still work with him yeah so I can go
back and say yeah art LeBeau is you can
listen I'm on k2 every Sunday night yeah
he's been at KD I want to say for the
last maybe four years now mm-hmm still
only at night though yeah I think it's
like Sundays at 6 o'clock from 6 to 12
midnight is that show recorded oh he
actually is there no he's he's it's a
live show
however he's not in the building he's I
want to say in Palm Springs and then
it's just as an ISDN yeah he has ISDN
line and so that's what they're doing
and we have somebody that runs the board
but it is live and the calls are live or
just recording their pre-recorded yeah
we have to be careful can't really go
live because if they cuss and it's like
a $25,000 fine but he's been in business
for a long time look I can't do these
people he isn't he is a legend an icon
to people like us in radio I think just
to the community in general because
people grew up on him we all know art
LeBeau so but as a radio personality and
when you get to talk to him and
it's just it's something different you
know you have to have respect for people
that have paved the way for you oh yeah
ask any diabetic total who do you pray
to God or the bow out of all homes he's
good people
yeah we probably me everything he shows
me love every Sunday night I don't know
even how you how he talked hey this is
art LeBeau another boat connection hey
thought oh boy this is an old connection
I'm a honey years old oh oh out LeBeau
when you're listening to Felipe
Esperanza he putting out my name the
same way I remember the only time memory
I have of him is seen in the sparse but
calling him Esperanza oh man his glasses
he come on old grouch from Mars no huh
well he's like he's not even I don't
even think he's five feet I think we're
seeing a hologram I think it's the four
ten maybe or something little dudes
super little yeah he was a [ __ ] ten he
did a big old show that the mouse went
to over there at a Glen Helen pavilion
which is now the salmon world pavilion
uh-huh a little oldie show and they
brought him onstage and he was really
small yeah very but he's the nicest guy
ever ever yes I did a show with him and
ninety back in the days at pudding stone
pudding so where was that at it's um
it's a park big part I don't know I
don't know the name of the park but
someone after 57 it's a big I used to be
called pleased to have in the 80s I
remember watching on television at
length and was that one of the first
place they had a water like well one of
the first water parks was San Dimas yeah
San Dimas right yeah no Brady water but
he water but never any water anymore but
not in the days it was something else
it was called Lake Elizabeth or like the
Laureus snake Dolores yeah we look at
water it was a water park with actually
metal slides broke dam metal bro so if
it was hot you're sitting in your burn
you're seeing bacon on it and I remember
he was hosting a show and it was
James Brown was there the coasters and I
opened the short I got to meet James
Brown
no you had that brown coat with the
little little fur on top like how was
James Brown and the Caesar waffle man
yeah it was nice
could they judge me as the comedian at
performing so real quick James Brown
this is the Camellia performing before
it was where you grew up
all right man man you go there man you
get that [ __ ] started man
took me around but man seeing him was
like I'm you know I would say like
meaning him
I guess people say me the feeling when
they meet someone great they like like
the Pope you know or someone be the
president but I felt like meeting the
president of so bro you can't [ __ ]
around my nipples are hard I got the
chills
my lines so just shook his hand and
walked away and man dude use big he's
building life you and I got to talk to
it the I got to talk to his homeboy so
when I put the cape on him the heart is
working that's like his height man that
was in there forever doc no critters
man's we're gonna talk business give it
up for dog whatever right
you put the cape on him him and I were
talking and man it was good and then
when he went we need when you were
leaving motorcade really two cars in the
front to counter the back white
limousine with two flags and then also
some forty roads white shake with her
big boobs I love you James Brown I don't
know who was set up but look good so so
meeting him Godfather so I get it but
like who is that who's the equivalent to
James Brown and comedy for you everybody
that Paul Rodriguez yes I couldn't talk
to him the first time I met him
so let's take a time when you brought
him a drink and I said donate to him
down to earth or cut up in yeah oh
that's the only been cool with me I
don't know these people who are who say
all man shows up it was rude to me
oh man Luis DK was rude to me or
parliament's a little rude to me
people have been rude to me oh that's
great
called me by fluency came on the first
time I met him he called me in a bone
and told me how good funny I was and
then when I met Paul I give you people
when you're a fan is different because a
fan of the not act a family I touch his
hair
you know pinch him all the words show
over the scrip joke or turn a [ __ ]
[ __ ] a [ __ ] movie or pitch a joke
right yeah it's real funny line you
should use it
Paul let me tell you about this [ __ ]
movie I got ok my part when part of the
show he get the [ __ ] out of there George
do the show he gets the [ __ ] out of
there
cuz they don't nobody talk to them you
know they don't want to hear nothing
about a man my my sister dying of cancer
she's right here we need $1,000 so
people beg how many beggars you have oh
my god how many people tell you how many
beep hello Carla number 35 25 [ __ ] you
oh no I get that
oh come on I just lost my job I'm
struggling right now you know it's been
hard they wear red it's I get the sad
story so I kind of go through the calls
fast because when I first started radio
I would listen to every sad story that's
me and then I put them on hold and I
would walk to the promotion story I'm
like is there something we can do I feel
bad yes and they're like see a thousand
people are gonna call we can't do that
for everybody you've got to get through
the calls fast and so I learned you know
to mean learned my lesson but I want to
help everybody I feel like oh they're
going through some really hard times
sorry bro were sold out but man if you
like show up at the end of the show and
hang up by the merch room I'll [ __ ]
make you laugh right there bro don't
solo bro can I get you in man but when
the show's over sneak into the theater
bro hang out with a mushroom much table
and I'll show up I think the worst part
though is like when you have a concert
and the day of the concert
everybody wants to call you and ask for
tickets or get in and I'm just like why
do they do this the day before the car
or the day of the concert know what
pisses me off more than fast calling me
up family members
yeah it's more yeah it's a lot of family
members and friends like you just
realized he was coming here tomorrow I'm
about to go up on stage in one hour I do
my father get out of the green room and
look to the [ __ ] box office
we're here we're standing up we're right
in Frank Oh when you walk out word to
the right oh he's telling me cats all
your Hollywood no no [ __ ] be
Hollywood if I was not famous if I don't
have nothing let's do it I went out of
my way to help you come on says he may
you know Chris Brown I love him just
high school to dinner
yeah well it's funny cuz like my
boyfriend works for soup so everybody
thinks that we can just call snoop up
and they're like um can you call snoopin
ask and we're like what excuse me it
doesn't work that way for Subrosa 13-3
rose it's like you wanna you start up
being a nice person but sometimes you
know and a some people know how you used
take advantage of that Oh everybody does
there's a lot of people that that take
advantage of it in and try and it's just
like or I get that I get the ones that
try to use like reverse psychology on me
like oh I see that you guys are giving
away ice cube tickets you know I've
never ever got to see them in concert
I've never answered you know I love ice
cube that's so good I wish I could see
him then you feel bad you feel guilty
you're like okay they're Loki trying to
ask me for tickets you know Cece you
don't understand man it's our
anniversary I get it - I understand why
she tastes girls - having kids by
herself she never been anywhere if she's
not gonna be anywhere he's gonna want to
make her happy we know when that person
stays I want to make her happy that's
what I say no more [ __ ] you want me to
make her happy
exactly you failed already you failed I
gotta pick up where you left off we're
taking over brother's show that we do
[ __ ] suck on the boyfriend I'm
sucking the husband
you suck on the person you don't care
about your girlfriend you don't care
about your wife you get one [ __ ] to
happen
easy but you know what's even worse than
those people though the people that want
to get on stage and perform with you or
want to get on sand you're like eh let
me open up and you go ahead and let me
open with it what is it gonna take and
you're like sexy I just need two minutes
to say
this message our stage five five I want
to say a message about doctor before you
go well how about ten shadows after I
know you're busy woman but a shout out
to the Pacheco family we drove from
Temecula that one always kills me
because you have to do an hour of
material and in between that do they
think you're gonna stop for like ten
shots exactly remember ten shout out
there's people that came for a reason I
try to remember going on
ceci we have the same name come on
you're blessed to have a platform you
know that's what we need we need that
yes exactly exactly
or you get these Latinos they're [ __ ]
get within five years of college got a
sociology degree good for you or
philosophy but can have no job but
they're asking you yes what what are you
doing to represent our people oh I
you know what you get the people that
are like what are you doing or you're
out there we did a walk for the homeless
and they were like oh my god you blocked
the streets of LA and it was like listen
either we participate or we don't but I
do I do community events every frickin
month what are you doing you know I it's
just people always rely on you you want
to rely on you to carry all the weight I
noticed that I've been this morning you
even mentioned doctor once we're never
saving the world
we have jobs you know at the end of the
day we work for a corporation yeah I go
for the improv
I'm work for power work for Katie like
at the end of the day I'm like do you
have boss I have a boss too and I have
to appease my boss just like you have to
peace yours you know what I mean so it
is what it is but yeah yeah yeah other
people say at the end of the day I just
want my [ __ ] card key to work your
job I'm just trying to pay our bills and
live life just like everyone
else listen man I do shoutouts but only
for envelopes that's right
tax them on those shoutouts station to
them give up free rent for a year like
I'd like but I wear now no no no we got
it we do a lot of other things but yeah
I've done that I pay people's bills
before and then you pay their bills and
it's not enough it's never ever end up
with your job yeah one last thing before
we go man
what's that I should buy her house
somehow the same what the [ __ ] get
through in the line you know I have a
girl that does that and she goes and
that's all she does is she stays home
and she calls radio stations so she'll
tell us like oh I'm coming to pick up
tickets from Katie and power and then
I'm gonna go to kiss-fm across the
street and we're like damn she's like
well this is what I do that's all she
doesn't stay home and call radio
stations and she wins tickets and then
either she sells him where she gives him
away it's so crazy like that and she
gets in all the time and then you'll get
people that are like I've tried calling
you for two years and I can't get into
my head I'm like why is this girl
getting in every single week what the
hell is she doing she has Verizon food
podcast with sexier mamacita
listen to on par 106 and then the
morning and Katie yes from 6:00 to be on
I'm on the J Crew show power 106 from
6:00 a.m. to 10:00 a.m. and you guys can
follow me social media and I am cccc
Valencia shut up do that homie or that
would send us Jeff Garcia he's actually
the show producer - yeah you know I
worked for it I worked for a Jeff Garcia
200 mornings but he was comedian not
producer what the [ __ ] bag yeah
what the [ __ ] like you know my money I
make from [ __ ] Jimmy Neutron [ __ ]
get this job [ __ ] hate those [ __ ]
helps I don't even I don't know why I
[ __ ] do radio man I could Pakistan on
our [ __ ] show man make more money
than what can do right now see my [ __ ]
tax comes away my [ __ ] wife a bucket
leaving me again go ahead and follow me
and I am [ __ ] breath my little
backward ass
congratulations to you last week I
couldn't go I got pulled over somebody
stole my car tags so I got pulled over
when I was I wanted to go and taste your
chilaquiles
oh yeah yeah I got pulled over somebody
stole my car - keeps it a real the
registration and the suits paid for they
still gave me a fix-it ticket oh yeah
even though they said your your tags are
up to you little slice through steel the
slices no no they take each likes they
take each slice pick at a time and then
put it in a wax paper believe it's care
that you know all this matter within
comedy yes and I am CC Valencia thank
you so much same thing and I am CC
Valencia if you go Torres and shows
before this week they say any jokes
tonight meet her all right we go what's
up fool